hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar patient-derived micro
tumor systems future trends towards
improved testing systems I am Judy
auroraco black roots and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by PerkinElmer
PerkinElmer is a global leader focused
on improving the health and safety of
people and the environment their
innovative detection imaging informatics
and service capabilities combined with
deep market knowledge and expertise help
customers gain greater insights into
their science let's get started this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits you can pose questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation wind metal questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker garry's are on
periasamy PhD platform leader at the
center for high-throughput genomics at
the genome Institute of Singapore dr.
Perry also means research focuses on the
cancer biology drug resistance disease
modeling and signaling pathway networks
of human diseases is able to run
high-throughput functional and chemical
genomics for target identification and
validation and proof of principle
studies dr. periasamy skirt focus is on
discovery and identification of novel
gene functions and phenotypes upon RNAi
mediated gene silencing or cDNA
overexpression foreign covering novel
mechanisms of drug resistance he plans
to develop
robust and comprehensive panels of 3d
cell culture models patient dr primary
cells for the characterization of
different disease phenotypes and
investigative chemo response to novel or
known drugs you would also like to
establish an array of next-generation
preclinical 3d tissue models for
predictive toxicology screening and
validation against traditional animal
model systems previously he worked as a
scientific director of the HTS HTS
screaming core facility at sea camp in
CVS India and as a group leader at
caramel life sciences limited in Mumbai
India dr. periasamy studied at the
center for biotechnology at anna
university where he obtained his PhD in
biotechnology he has more than 15
significant publications and eight
patents to his credit dr. periasamy will
now begin his presentation hi I'm
welcoming everyone to this webinar which
is sponsored by perkinelmer I'm going to
discuss about the patient arrived micro
tema systems which is a future trend
towards improving the testing system by
four for us to realize the potential of
HTS and SCS actually which is a high
throughput and high content screening so
in this slide we are I'm going to
discuss about how this evolution of HTS
assist strategies for the past decade
because initially the HTS was largely
focused on bio chemical based like which
is like a enzyme substrate reaction and
people will look out for the readout I
think as the technology improved towards
the high content screening which is like
a high content imaging so we can look at
the specific changes in the nucleus or
in the or in the tubulin or and in the
specific proteins so like when those
technologies have started improving i
think this high throughput is also is
coupled with a high content screen
because with the technology evolvement
actually you can see that like how be
like people can phenotype now actually
because this is what does leads to the
the there is a revolution in the high
high-throughput screening I think people
have started looking back into the
high-throughput screening and for the
for the meaningful target identification
or drug development so so what like what
is a different types of high content
screening system can can offer a
different type of assays to us I think
here you are seeing equipment which is
of Phoenix which is one of the latest
version from the PerkinElmer we have
this in our platform here in Singapore I
think which we are using this particular
code technology bye-bye different users
of different disease biology groups to
run their high throughput and high
content screening so here we can do
fixed seller says and we can do life
cell and also we can do a complex
cellular models like 3d models and then
protein-protein interaction studies and
we can also try like basically this
release to the hyper pod phenotyping
because in a when level data or we can
select the cell level data which can be
followed by the further by the deep
analysis of Columbus and other other
later softwares so there is a need for
us to generate relevant in vitro models
in order to go back to the translational
research or whatever we do in the bench
if we want a complete translation impact
of what we are trying to do so I think
if you see this the the different type
of cell culture or the animal model say
for example if it is a 2d cell culture
or if it is a 3d or if it is organoid
you can see the ease of manipulation is
is it as it is easy because if you
wanted to run our say very quickly and
if you wanted to have a very
reproducible data in terms of like savor
ratio is close to ninety to ninety-five
percent of three per disability then I
think people that's how the screening
they previously actually because a lot
of people were in two dimensional cell
cultures but I think if you see the
whatever the output we are going to see
in this particular screening effort
actually because if you see the green
line the more power which we are getting
it is only for from the the highly
complex models actually I think I think
that's why I think some of our groups
here in Singapore actually right now we
are we are working on a lot of 3d models
as well as on the organoids model now in
order to derive the more relevant and
also the meaningful information which
can be translated back into the clinic
so I think to do this I think I think we
have a high content biology basically
like I can talk about this basically
like you can look into the cell cycle of
the team SL morphology or you can look
into the skeletal muscle morphology or
or like say hepatic morphology or like
you can look into the genotoxicity by
looking specifically into the nucleus so
based on this technology the way it has
come up right now so people have now
agree visiting revisiting the phenotype
based drug discovery because earlier the
target based drug discovery rights from
the enzymes isolated enzymes and then
you look for an enzyme substrate
reaction and then you find our own a
store antagonist then you come into the
cell based assays but now I think now
because since we have this high content
approaches so people are now trying to
embarrass the biological complexity of
creating a much more relevant haces for
the particular disease model I think
that is going to give advance advantage
for for every disease model because we
are going to look like we are going to
gain the basic informations which is
going to be really useful for the for
the translational effort
I think I'm coming into the cancer right
I think everyone knows us I think human
cancers or completely heterogeneous so
it is like every thumbprint how it is
different so every tumor is also
different so so people are and the
people are looking the cancer at the
different angle because it is not like a
one busy it is it is driven by multiple
dysregulated pathways that can reach to
the cancer and when you when you look
into this there is a complex disease
network in cancer and also like how we
can handle this efficiently because you
can see how these are all interlinked
you can you can look at this in the two
different level like a like a patient
level and also at the molecular level so
at the patient level also every patient
is different because you may not see a
response for the same drug for us or a
similar phenotype when you find it and
give it to them also because sometimes
the patient response is is completely
unexpected actually so this is because
of how these the some of the major
dysregulated pathway or the or the some
of the minor pathways which are
responding to the truck and how it is
giving back sometimes a relax because of
the one of the major things which we are
talking in cancerous is a relapse and
the resistance so how this cancer
genomics is going to help for this from
the discovery of science to the
personalized medicine so basically when
when patient comes to the clinic they'll
get the patient consents and then they
will look for their cancer genomics like
like specific mutations Seifert is the
best cancer they will look for what kind
of phenotype it is so if it is a lung
cancer they will look for easier for
positive or negative on what kind of
mutations they have so and then they
will validate and then they will use
they will use their knowledge to
identify the drug targets and the
biomarkers then they will finally they
will try to select the truck that
might work for that particular patients
so before going into the the
personalized on to oncology approach
which we are doing at our GIS along in
Singapore I would like to show this the
way we do screens the different type of
screens which will give much more
relevant data which are completely
translatable to the animal model and
also like we have done one co clinical
setting in which we have seen that the
patient is kind of benefited from the
guide from the kind of the decision
which which which talk to us derive from
our research work so i think if you we
are looking at this image pay screams to
determine the therapeutic sensitivity so
here we have a two different cell types
I think this these are all primary human
like primary cancer direct cell lines so
they are labeled with a green color dye
and another one is with the TG tomato
wedges red color so say for example if
it is a primary and a med cell lines you
can label them separately and then what
we used to do is we can feed them
together in a 384-well plate and we will
do a just image-based screen and where
we can look into the the compound which
are killing both like primary and met
which may be completely toxic or maybe
nonspecific but we have also found some
compounds that are specific to read
which is a myth metastatic cell line and
in the same screen we found some
compounds that can kill specifically
primary cells so I think the bases the
basic idea is here to light because in a
one single screen we will be able to
find out like the compounds which can
kill specifically to this and I think we
have shown the ic50 graph here which can
tell you the ic50 difference between the
sum of the selected
compounds and also the bottom line
bottom two which shows that like this
compound is showing this compound is
showing a equal activity on human
primary as well as human metastatic cell
line set up so I think what we do is
actually when we do a screens in 2d and
in a parallel e we have also started
implicating the of like we wanted to
develop a robust in with true 3d
architectural screens in parallel to the
2d screens because we have seen the
whatever the team is or which is which
is like it will be good like whatever
the response which we are seeing in 2d
screens if you translate them back into
the into the 3d model so we have seen
the the number of failures in the
further validation is completely lesser
so I think we are going to have a one
more validation step I think that's why
we have developed this model you can see
clearly how these cells looks like you
know one day after feeding and then that
like then we will wait for three days
which is like the day zero of untreated
and then you can see once you add some
specific compound which which targets a
specific pathway so people can easily
find out like how this ground state as
well as destruction Stutes state are are
responding to the treatment so I think
using this model like what we have data
is actually be compared or similar same
amount of cells in 2d as well as in the
3d and using the same media components
in both the cases we just try to see
like if there is any difference in the
in the activity when then the cells are
grown and 2d or when the cells are
growing in a 3d model so what we did
like we took e we took a FD uproot our
and kinase inhibitors molecules as a
screening so we screened around close
800 plus compounds in this so I think
this particular cluster which is showing
like the column one is like the if the
2d model and column two is 3d model
screen for the same compounds because on
the on the y axis we have the name of
the compounds but I think all these
compounds were clustered to the specific
pathways which are in the x axis that is
what we are seeing you can see there are
some specific node you can see some
specific node for example like there is
a differential activity which we are
seeing here so that is what we were
looking for actually because we wanted
to select some compounds which
specifically act more active in 3d but
in the same time it is not showing that
that similar activity in a 2d model so i
think the other screen is also more
robust so we are we are seeing this here
because our we are saying this here
because it's showing a very clear
correlation was like really good so then
like based on that primary screen data
then we have further validated and we
found that so the pi3k pathway compounds
and also the another related pathways SP
80km to a pathway we have seen these
compounds showed more response in in a
3d model compared to be 2d model
actually because you can see this region
which are
we can see these two regions which is
showing a clear effect on you can see
the difference between 2d and 3d model
so what we did like then we wanted to
check like what kind of a gene
expression profile which is changing
when they lend us the same cell line
when it is growing in a 2d or versus a
3d model so what we did we took same
cell line like me we took like two
different cell line which is like hn 120
these are all primary patient arrived
cell line we took glycogen 120 and
another one like Haitian 137 so when we
are looking for a different markers like
socks on nanos vimentin and another
range of IP Celia emt markers so we have
seen like then when cells are grown and
grown in a 3d model this particular
phenotype is matching with the which is
which is the patient teamer how it is
behaving in the human system so then
what else we have also done like some of
the high content imaging you can see the
how this particular cell line has been
staying for specific markers like cd44
in this case so we have done this using
our phoenix and you can see this if you
can study the basically how this
particular marker this is effective in
this so overall what we have done we
have we have extrapolated this kind of a
screening instrument and ten different
cell line models so i think this
particular the difference in inhibition
scores between the 3d and 2d is giving
us a clue that it will be better if you
have a 2d model and also we should have
a 3d model in place to find out because
they in the 2d model from this
particular data
from this particular data we can see
these regions are specific for 2d and
this regions are specific for duty
because these are like tlk or a
microtubule-associated compounds which
is basically like a proliferation
inhibitor but it's like some of the
specific pathway like em to pay 3k and
another major pathways you can see this
is like a number of compounds which are
responding to this so these are specific
to 3d so then like what we read like we
also did I invite or validation of the
highly active compound and we found that
whatever the hits we found and 3d models
we showed a more activity it showed the
clear tumor regression compared to the
vehicle so I think this is this is a
very recent data which we have obtained
so I think based on this actually now we
have a model where we can we can we can
understand or we can study the number of
drugs and then we can give a output to
say that actually okay this particular
patient team our cells is going to
respond to any specific truck of what we
are testing right so I think like based
on this input from the different labs
and other different places so now there
is an evolution of the cancer treatment
is basically you know you know in a
world to paradigm the doctors used to
give a drug and say that okay if it is
not working they will switch they will
switch so basically it's like a trial
and error prescribing some time because
it doesn't suit every patient all the
time with the way the right drug in the
in the first choice so the idea is to
bring like efficient medical care which
is like a new paradigm which now every
hospitalists moving into so we're what I
think the advantage of this new paradigm
is this is going to help in this is
going to help in selection of the
optimal therapy and also this will also
reduce a trial and error prescribing and
this will help to avoid adverse drug
reactions and this will improve the
quality of life and also reveal the
additional or alternative uses for a
medicines are all d of the drug
candidates so I think what we do in our
high throughput final mix as well as in
the inner arm dasgupta lab here in Jas
is I think rom is the one who is
completely coordinating this resource
appreciation on quality so II he had a
lot of collaborations with the local
hospital fear which is a National Cancer
Center or or HGH so he has a close our
relation in working with dr. Gopal Iyer
and dr. Lyanne tanneal from from a sec
ssl she is so when the patient comes to
the clinic the patient team is implanted
in my sls and they were trying to expand
it as a primary cell cultures so this is
like some time we will directly derive
directly derive this is pd pc disk
patient-derived primary sense or
sometime then like we will grow them and
we will also barcode them and we are
maintaining a biobank of this and when
these cells are multiplied in a in a
larger scale this will subjects to
high-throughput screen height super
screen so then whatever the data we are
seeing in this which will be further
validated in the pdx model and so
whatever the data output we are getting
in this the response data will be shared
with the doctor
to help our guide pretreatments strategy
for this particular patient if he are
like gee if he did they are coming back
to the clinic with her with a real app
setting or would be kind of a resistant
modern luxury i think that time this
model will be useful so the next slide
huh so here i am going to discuss like
how our models are closely represent p
the patient humor so you can see our
gene expression data like this is the
patient direct the the tumors which is
which is which are exercised from from
the human so we have subjected to gene
expression analysis and this is well you
can see which is 0 point nine seven
which is for the when the same tumor
when it is growing in the mouse model
and this is our cell line which is point
nine five so the advantage here is
actually what we are seeing the
expression correlation between over
mortal eyes from between our models
three different models actually is
completely highly correlated and also we
have tested this hardon expression it is
also similar across different model
which is close to 0 point nine 2.95
across different settings so which which
which is kind of giving us a confidence
that i think the theme or complexity
which we are seeing in the ish we are
seeing in the in in vivo condition which
is still making at the level of pdx us
also the patient there are primary cell
line models so which is very very useful
for testing the multiple drugs on the
particular cell line models so we
expanded this says because a hyena laugh
so then what we did like we used to do
is like we used to test them against the
the set of fta
proved anti-cancer drugs and then our
initial data showed some of the some of
the specific compounds which are working
on a specific patient tumor lines here
so these are all like a different
patients like h and 13 7 1 2014 8 15 9
and 1 60 so the then we will like what
we did like whatever the expressions we
have seen so that is also correlated
with the molecular gene signatures which
we found like say some of some of the
drugs which we found ourselves cdk
inhibitor as a top rate and we have also
seen there is such a regulation of this
particular pathway which we can found in
the same similar cell type and also our
subsequent validation in the Indies in
the same patient-derived xenograft model
has shown that these compounds whatever
we found in the Indian vitro screen is
showing a very good correlation in the
in in the enviro setting us also so this
gives us the confidence that this piece
whatever the output which we are seeing
from this data should be useful to the
clinic or like this can be a basis for a
step for a translational research so I
think dr. rom and gopal they were when
there when they were working on a one
particular patient so they found that
Jeff it in ur can be more effective to
this patient based on the data which we
have seen which we have seen in the lab
you can see this data which is which is
more effective for this particular
patient arrived femur line and then we
tested them on the in vitro model as
well so there also we have seen the
they're also we have seen this this the
receiver equations
so then based on the co clinical
settings at like 10 ccs in singapore dr.
caball can give has tried this
particular medicine which we have found
that which is which is showing a better
response compared to the other standard
of care and we have also seen basically
this this whatever the data which we
have seen in the in vitro condition is
clearly worked in the clinic at least in
the n equal to 1 ko clinical trial
settings so I think this is a one of the
best example of how we can develop this
phenotype in driven position oncology so
right now what we are trying to do is we
are trying to increase the numbers we
are trying to increase the numbers
number of patients here and then we are
trying to add like a genomics and equity
normal gene expression and rec response
data we wanted to use this as a mission
learn tool to find out suppose if you do
this for a 25 different types of
patients maybe we will come back with a
with a novel biomarker or like a novel
signature that can predict the again the
drug response in a in a real time to the
equations so that is a hope for us to
put more effort on phenotype driven
position oncology at GIS and so after
that particular portion so what I wanted
to show this so apart from the our focus
on 2d models and 2d models and then 3d
models and then how we use those models
to do the triple the oncology approach
where we can find out how the specific
trucks are working for it so here I am
going to show you some quickly like what
all the different other works which we
are also doing like using
high-throughput or a high content
screening mutters I think what we are
trying to do the settings of
Judy school issues our computational
feel on genomics platform leader I think
she put this kind of where she developed
a database it's like a chemical parts a
profiler so what it came to us is like
we are trying to create a bio CV for the
set of molecule something here we have
worked close to around 15 15,000
compounds we have tested them on like
different pathways like grk wind make
Simic and J&K and all the pathways I
think you can see this clusters which
are showing clusters which are showing
like the compounds against the specific
pathway activity so which will be useful
for the small selection of small
molecules or you can identify like how
one similar staff polish showing
multiple effect so this is an example of
how this web interface can be helpful to
be the different scientific community
when they reach us I think we can show
them that ok it's like they can select
the sum of the pathway which are
upstream or downstream they can they can
select a very focused library based on
this particular effort which we have put
it on different compounds they can
identify the compound connectivity map
like say which can they can infer the
protective target of uncharacterized
compounds so this will be an additional
step which will like which will help
them to select the particular compounds
and this is another image based truck
screening which we have done so in which
the cells are labeled with different
colors and like we have test them with a
set of fda-approved anti-cancer library
you can see like how these particular
cell lines are reacting to be because
like we have also worked with I think
the previous study which i have
discussed it is with oral squamous cell
carcinoma and this one is the choleric
cancer so i think we are we are coming
to be another one this is the platform
where i am leading here in singapore
which is which is chip GIS scholars
center for high-throughput phenom x I
think our effort here is I think we are
working and supporting the different
investigator initiated programs in
giving the expertise in sa automation
and miniaturization chassis automation
and miniaturization and also we will do
lot of chemical and functional genomics
and we do gain assumptions and
loss-of-function studies using crisper
or SAR shrna and we have different
annotated libraries for small molecules
as well as functional genomics I think
people who are interested to screen or
like to know more about high throughput
and high [ __ ] and screen you can follow
our website which is chip she is a star
dot edu so this will give you the clue
of what we are doing here on a day to
day basis and this is the the companion
computational platform which is lead by
dr. Judas I told you because she's
developing lot of infrastructure
development because for all the height
super screen if you don't have an
end-to-end solutions the data will look
really redundant because I think all our
high-throughput screening stata has been
gone through this pipeline and she will
bring in this the ease of analysis and
also the interpretations to move forward
I think this platform is very very
useful to give an end-to-end solutions
for all high throughput as well as all
image-based screams so with this I am
ending this presentation I would like to
acknowledge dr. Braam and his team in
gif Singapore and dr. Koh PHA liar and
his team in sec a Singapore dr. yen and
dr. Daniel at ajs and NZ here's and I
would like to thank my team from Center
for high-throughput phenom Ock's
I would like to thank dr. Hawke is
executive directors GIS singapore and i
would like to thank dr. jonathan and
also the perkinelmer team for this
wonderful support for this wonderful
support so with this I would like to end
this presentation I can take up
questions now thank you
thank you dr. periyasaamy for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box sound by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left at the presentation window
dr. periyasaamy will answer as many
questions as time permit for a first
question is how do you determine which
signaling networks or pathways are to be
investigated or screened in your current
study for example oncogenic metastatic
anti-apoptotic and immune modulation etc
yeah hi is a very important question
when we do a phenotypic screens
sometimes we may not know the direct
targeting engagement I think the way we
do this part of pathway analysis by high
content biology approach using the
phoenix system that we have from the PE
so so what we can do is using this
approach we can derive the target
protein engagement and also we can study
the changes in the cellular phenomena
like nuclear morphology and membrane
changes we can we can track this
information up to the purse cell level
data using this the deep imaging of high
content imaging so which is not feasible
in in say for example in the in the
Western gloss say you will take the
whole licet so you won't be able to see
what is happening in the Purcell level
data so with redditors with respect to
this phenotype X cleaning approach I
think we can do this by by deep imaging
called like high content imaging here
next one is we'll be looking at any
genotypic correlation in the patient
based on the pathway specific inhibitor
identified yes absolutely because the
whole idea behind this approach is to
build a novel correlations between the
between the individual drug response
which is corresponding to the gene
expressions and the mutation status that
when we are doing this as a pipeline so
what we are trying to do this yet
whether we are also in parallel we are
doing vgn expression and the mutation
status studies for that particular
patients so when we do this for our more
people I think that that will enable us
to determine the novel biomarkers while
we scale up the studies actually that's
that's a advantage well i would like to
once again thank dr. periyasaamy forest
regeneration do you have any final
comments for yeah I think yeah I think
and this one's approach which which a
lot of people are getting into this
right now so I think people are using
this particular the patient arrived
chemo systems as a as I infer to move
forward in be in the more advancing the
development thank you again I'd also
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we do not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank our sponsor
perkinelmer for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CT button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on demand through
October 20th 2017 lab roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time bye